what is the European Council around the  table you have 28 real leaders each of  them is well-prepared intelligent  ambitious decisive even bossy leading  the other works of such a team is a real  challenge  what is however more important is the  fact that they are almost always able to  find a common thread ready to risk or  sacrifice individual interests for the  sake of agreement this is the essence of  political Europe to argue to debate to  negotiate but always in good will and  one more important thing it is really a  democratic body with a democratic  legitimacy the best proof of this is the  fact that almost every European Council  I say goodbye for good to somebody and  welcome somebody else voters in Europe  constantly renew the composition of the  European Council which makes this work  so fascinating for all of us